a senior Primary Care the sponsors of
this segment they're back to remind
older adults that medical needs change
as you age of course and they are here
to guide you
Dr Wakefield welcome back
oh it's great to be here thank you good
to see you again we're talking about
your senior focused care with Center
well um you know what do seniors need to
know about their health care after age
65.
we'll just realize at age 65 seniors are
eligible for Medicare which really comes
with a great amount of benefits so it's
really important to find a doctor on
your Medicare plan that that you trust
someone who is patient and gives you
time to discuss all the aspects of your
health including emotional and physical
and social health because it's all
interconnected
for sure that's a great point and for
those who actually really love their
doctor
um what should they do next what what
are steps that they need to take well
some of the things you got to keep in
mind is that as we age our health care
often transitions from prevention to
reaction at Center well we practice
value-based care which means that we are
focused on preventative medicine so we
work closely with patients to help keep
them healthy as they age for those
living with say chronic conditions such
as diabetes we have entire programs and
Care regimens designed to keep them
living as well as possible so instead of
just seeing your doctor when you don't
feel well it's also important for
seniors to start thinking about seeing
their primary care doctor a little more
often this is so your doctor and Care
team always have a current understanding
of your state of health even if you feel
great you should make regular visits to
your doctor for testing or evaluations
you may need and to really discuss your
health as openly and in as much detail
as you can
and you mentioned the older seniors with
Advanced health conditions any other
information you want to give them on how
they should be living oh absolutely at
Center well we we specialize in caring
for people who are in the entire
spectrum of our seniors and we know that
younger seniors and older senior seniors
have really very different needs if an
older patient is ill the care team may
track them while they're in the hospital
and support them during their discharge
if they're lonely are on-site Activity
Center offer daily programming to keep
them socially connected if they're
struggling with food medicine finances
or housing our social workers have
resources to support them from healthy
Aging in retirees to older seniors with
extensive needs we are really
comfortable taking care of our patients
throughout the senior Spectrum
and I know there are some seniors out
there watching right now who are saying
I want to see Dr Wakefield I want to see
her so how do they become patients with
Central wealth so it's really easy to
become a patient here at Central well I
would recommend visiting
centerwelllasvegas.com you can see where
all our locations are located throughout
the valley and you can even come into
our Center and have a personalized tour
we're really always happy to you know
welcome new patients looking for great
care
thank you to Center well senior primary
care for sponsoring that segment for
more information just head to
centerwelllasvegas.com